elton john les élus on va en parler
parce que son biopic le biopic est sorti
sur lui est un carton total au cinéma en
fait tu pas un terrain juste que j'étais
tout à l'heure tu allais oublier mon
show ça tu es tout en noir on dirait une
bonne corse mon sujet là que tu es en
deuil
ah non elle est prête à la culture
française en étant transparent là d'où
je suis là bas l'autre c'est pas
possible qu'elle nettoie les angels ont
donc le biopic c'est rocket man et pour
être le plus fidèle rôle dont sharon et
geert stone l'acteur qui n'a pas de
chanteur britannique affirme qu'il a pu
sans les dire la finition donc au jour
où le mec lui a dit pardon mais comment
vous avez pu en étant si beau
interpréter un acteur s'il est voilà la
question qui lui a dit c'est assez
étonnant donc on s'est posé la question
comment peut-on réussir et pourrait-on
encore aujourd'hui réussir lorsqu'on a
un physique on va dire atypique pour ne
pas dire un peu disgracieux regardez
après on va parler vous allez voir que
c'est assez surprenant parce
qu'aujourd'hui
finalement tous les mômes sortes
d'émissions de télé où ils sont tous
beaux et les jeunes ont voté pour eux et
finalement on a plus de personnes un peu
atypique à la télévision ou chez les
artistes
regardez la semaine dernière cela n'a
pas pu vous échapper il sortit rocketman
le biopic consacré à elton john
être que j'aurais dû être plus banal
tu n'es jamais été banale
outre ses qualités de musicien elton a
une autre particularité en physique pas
facile comment est ce qu'un petit gros
sorti de nulle part
peut devenir une star karon egerton le
beau gosse qui joue elton john dans le
film n'y va d'ailleurs pas par quatre
chemins elton m'a donné la permission de
lui donner un aspect moche parfois
comprenait plus 10 kg calvitie naissante
et ce sourire qu'on vous laisse
apprécier mais constatons ensemble que
le physique troublant d'elton john n'est
en rien un frein à son succès et diable
la liste est longue de nos stars fort
mal dotés par la nature
et pourtant adulée freddie mercury à la
dentition proéminente était surnommé le
décapsuleur se parent gentil gentil st
et susan boyle n'a guère peut mettre en
avant son physique cela ne l'a pas
empêché d'être numéro un des ventes en
angleterre il ya neuf ans d'autres
personnalités ont le talent de faire
diversion changer d'europe tous les
quarts d'heure et s'il ya plus de rabat
ou continuer dans la catégorie pour
certains ont très vite compris qu'il
fallait passer par la case relooking
extrême ou carrément il ya les au
scalpel quant à ceux qui ne se montre
tout simplement pas on peut imaginer le
pire alors peut-on réussir avec un
physique hors norme
[Applaudissements]
j'ai vu bien pire le biopic sera pour
ceux qui n'ont pas vu c'est vraiment ma
magnifique et c'est vrai la question
qu'on s'est posée et enfin mathieu qui
connaissent bien tu as écrit un bouquin
sur johnny et là je rigole pas le que
des bilans aussi les gens qui font de la
musique s'est interrogé dans deux
minutes parce que c'est une vraie
question
elton john voilà il avait pas de cheveux
il avait un physique un peu disgracieux
on peut penser à polnareff aussi ce qui
va les yeux un peu tous rapprochés qui
sait créer un look avec ses lunettes
est ce qu'aujourd'hui ce serait possible
pardon on va dire les mots peut-être
d'être moche et aujourd'hui d'espérer
faire une carrière artistique c'est une
vraie question
j'ai la réponse mais je ne la donne pas
tiens justement à propos de personnes
mais on peut être très beau ressembler à
kent et paraît sûre du tout oui mais
c'est pas la question
elle avait tout charger fut si ça marche
bien c'est pas enrayée elle a marché
pour de vrai ce qu'on peut ou pas c'est
sûr qu'on peut à un moment donné faut
arrêter le contraire mais je trouve que
les gens il aime les gens un peu disert
les gens disaient mécontents du relais
les gens différents les gens atypiques
etc
et franchement oui bien sûr benata vent
sur scène c'était une blague édition
basée sur toi et moi j'aimerais un petit
peu de fond mathieu gainsbourg disait
cette phrase la likouala t'as vu t'as vu
c'est pas moi je pense que les gens y
croient
[Rires]
c'est cool mathieu aniche a pas but de
la laideur est supérieure à la beauté
parce qu'elle dure parce qu elle ne
disparaît pas avec le hall à la jules
verbal des intellectuels oui je vais
vous dire je pense qu'aujourd'hui il
était très difficile d'être très beau et
de faire carrière dans la musique j'ai
pas d'exemple de personnes réellement
très très belle personne qui a fait une
carrière très grande chance n'est pas
parce que les gens sont un tout petit je
suis en répétant ses côtés géniale idée
il est sublime îles samoa cas merci
ouais que l'eau la chose qui compte
c'est le charisme et le charisme ça n'a
rien à voir à qui nous est bon ou pas
vous savez qui a cassé les standards de
beauté en france dans les années 70 on
risquait ya un acteur et un acteur
mythique dont vous êtes fan faire sans
elle c'est jean paul belmondo
ouais le professeur de théâtre de jean
paul belmondo pierre gagick lui disait
toi tu ne seras jamais une femme dans
les bras parce que tu étape à la beauté
claisse à ce qu'il avait un physique de
boxeur et casser les boxeurs il a
dénoncé tous les standards suite elle me
on a pu la voir des gentils petit
champlain à québec
mais quand vous voyez quelle époque on
voit dans le film ballet mais les mecs
avec plein de textes vous allez voir le
patron d'universal tout à l'époque et
berkeley ils montraient leurs textes
mecque des et chante c'est bien c'est
pas bien je te donne une chance je pense
qu'aujourd'hui le mec le plus talentueux
du monde qui est moche il arrive dans
une maison de disques et dior et déchets
c'est très bien chanté on dirai merci
beaucoup mais à l'époque de the voice et
tous où l'image compte beaucoup
on ne sortirait pas de singles et c'est
bien sûr ça aide il ya une étude qu'il
ya une étude qui qui qui qui est sorti
en angleterre il ya pa très rarement aux
états unis.vers de rabia pas très
longtemps
comme quoi alors j'ai tous les chiffres
combien doit les bosses ont payé plus
que les moches à 20% il ya une vraie
prime à la beauté je n'avais rien les
baux sont plus élus les baux se disent
heureux à 10% de plus que les moches
sari ou sont moins condamné dans les
tribunaux c'est pas vrai et beau sont
moins condamné dans les tribunaux et ils
ont deux fois moins de chances de faire
deux doigts d'aller en prison dont deux
sens entre césar ils sont aussi défendu
par un avocat qui équivaut aussi qui est
beau oui mais c'est fou dit merde
en revanche parce que ça ne représentait
pas en revanche ça vous concerne pour
finir les baux sont plus prompts à
divorcer et les femmes belles a priori
on toujours l'étiquette de elle est
belle et stupide en gros il faut être
beau et avoir des petits défauts c'est à
dire moi ok c'est intéressant ce qu'il
dit mais personne répondant à la
question est-ce qu'aujourd'hui a gagné
on a déjà vu un gagnant de the voice ou
d'un télé crochet on les a tous vus tous
ceux qui sortent olivier minne qui
votent pas pour le salon c'est tout le
monde vous vraiment avait pas mais il ya
les gens qui ont du talent je pense que
si ces virées à même si peu fier aussi
des gens qui parlent de foot mais du
sport grand chose myriam catherine à
excuser moi prenons un point lifting à
la chaîne avait la peau ici eh ben on en
reste le shar pei regarder la télévision
depuis ses ailes non il était une
luminance queue leu leu le marché
aujourd'hui du disque c'est tous les
tous les candidats ou même les chanteurs
sont extrêmement marketé et sortent et
surpris parce que voilà ils ont un
physique
les seuls qui qui échappent qui
échappent cds cheran d angleterre et
encore mais me le dise bon ils ont misé
sur leurs différences mais ils ont bien
galéré avant c'est sûr que quand on est
beau et qu'on chante bien de raisons de
réussir j'ai tout donné par lens et
rêveur est encore un petit peu de temps
mais encore une fois je n'ai pas un
exemple aujourd'hui c'est une personne
qui a vraiment un physique où tu te dis
bon c'est vraiment moi je dis à tous
bien si c'est l'organe officieux il
marche très bien
magalie vaé l'apab ont dû d'ailleurs
alors qu'il veut parler c'est pas la
préhistoire christophe willem et julien
doré franchement là bien doré rachat
attendez vous à ce que tu te tais pas et
que du coup comment il était pendant les
fêtes c'est le grand beau ils étaient
quinze mille pattes ou sans lui même se
décrivait c'est pas moi il disait un
petit gros avec des lunettes des culs de
bouteille show man 3 enfin il échoue
vous faut redire et d'effacer les joies
et délices qui fais pas des films
justement dans quel film il en vend
maintenant quand arrive et que tu te dis
voilà gt gt comme ça tu t'étais un peu
grosse et des lunettes tu perds tes
cheveux tmh 1 devant un dilemme de la
patron de 10 qui étudie aujourd'hui est
une bouteille sur scène et qu'on paye
pour venir me voir c'est assez facile à
développer son excentricité on chez toi
et les regarder jouer par exemple pardon
c'est pour ça qu'ils d'ailleurs il est
très excentrique et on voit très bien
son cas lui lady gaga en fait toutes ces
personnes qui ont un physique un peu
atypique et ben vont basculer dans
l'excentricité pour voilà pour faire
diversion entre huy se font un look lady
gaga paul leray parce que leur maison
disque aujourd'hui ces quelques arrêts
avec une voix sublime qui joue très bien
du piano qu'il est super et c'est si le
type est pas terrible je suis étonné
aujourd'hui quand même mort on le voit
autour de cette table les gens passent
un peu triché sur leur physique mais
j'ai même vous dire un truc denrées
voice dans the voice
ils sont là ils entendent une voix elle
se retourne parfois ces ruptures et les
huiles fond et tu vas les jus les merdes
et comme par hasard le battle d'après il
lui mais contre un mec hyper doué et
puis j'ai vu les deux ont du talent mais
toi qui es moche que toi qui es je ne
vais pas le garder de mon équipe c'est
un peu vrai il écrira un peu les moins
beau